لم يتعهد الرئيس الفرنسي بارسال دبابات
لكلير القتاليه الشهيره الى اوكرانيا لكنه
لم يستبعد ذلك وشكل ما قاله تطورا نسبيا
في موقف باريس تحدث عن معايير محدده
ستراعى في حال ارسال هذه الدبابات
تصعيديه وان تؤمن هذه الدبابات دعما
حقيقيا وفعليا لاصدقائنا الاوكرانيين
اما المستشار الالماني الذي توقع ان تستمر
الحرب في اوكرانيا لفتره طويله جدا فقد
بقي جوابه غامضا بشان احتمال
اثنين نحن خلال عقود لم نقدم سلاحا للدول
التي تعيش النزاعات من دون نهايه الحرب
العالميه الثانيه لكننا غيرنا سياستنا
بالتنسيق خصوصا مع امريكا وفرنسا ودول
اوروبيه اخرى
تحدث لنا عضو لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
والدفاع في مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي جيل
بالرجاء عن ضروره ارسال دبابات قتاليه
لحمايه اوكرانيا ومن خلفها كل اوروبا
مسيرات الايرانيه وارسال الدبابات قادره
على التحرك السريع
جاء في البيان الختامي والاعلان المشترك
الفرنسي الالماني ان البلدين حريصان على
شراكه اطلسيه قويه كلام يعكس تقارب
اللفظيا بين باريس وبرلين فيما الخلافات
حول قضايا الدفاع والطاقه ما زالت كامله
براي مراقبين الازمه الصامته بين قطبي
الاتحاد الاوروبي الرئيسيين اولا حول
تباين حاجتين الى الغاز الروسي وثانيا حول
عدم وجود رؤيه دفاعيه اوروبيه مشتركه ذهبت
برلين بعيدا عن باريس اول نحو الصين ثم
نحو الولايات المتحده ودول اخرى في حلف
النيته وكادت تتعامل حتى مع اسرائيل حول
منظومه صاروخيه
من ان تعزيل نفسها اوروبيه فتراجعت في
الشكل واللهجه على الاقل حسين قنيبر
العربيه من قصر الاليزيه باريس